this is Startalk every astrophysicist is
also a physicist this is how that works
exactly like my undergraduate degree is
in physics in physics just to set that
so yard you know it's me and physics go
way back yet so you got it you can't you
can't become an astrophysicist without
becoming a regular for regular Phasis
it's that the deal yeah yeah that's
pretty much the deal I'm probably half
of my colleagues have degrees in physics
before they got the PhD in astrophysics
right and even if they didn't half their
classes are all in physics okay so now
here's my other question yeah can you be
an astrophysicist without being a PhD I
perhaps but an astrophysicist the PhD
forget that it's an education level the
PhD is demonstration that you can
perform original research on the
frontier of cosmic discovery okay so if
you can do that at the Masters level
sure I'll call you back all your
national physicists right but at the
Masters level the training is less
refined to get to that point that's all
so you're more of a Padawan was that say
Jedi in training okay excuse me from
just geeking out for a second by the way
there are people who are at the
undergraduate level or at the Masters
level who have their names on research
papers but generally they are topics
that are selected by their advisers who
do have the PhDs do understand where the
frontier is and how to how to advance it
right so so that that's how that plays
yeah but you're still not an
astrophysicist
you just got your name on the research
paper you got your name on a research
paper that's a start it's a that's kind
of like look at the telescope and
discovering something that nobody has
ever seen before and they named it after
you you're still not an as we just
haven't be a good dude look up at the
right time right that's it right right
and the right place and the right place
this
is Startalk